you
the tournament is already starting okay
king of the hill is where we're at don't
try to run towards the center real quick
you see these four highlighted squares
king of the hill get your King in the
center and you win
I shouldn't have cancelled so quick
let's back up what a sneaky King
get out of there King not taking you
take me I'll take now No
huh I want to keep the Queens on the
board their King is too close let's go
here 39 seconds the check um check
get out of there King I don't want you
anywhere near those four Center squares
he's sticking around I'm gonna I'm gonna
weasel my king around to look at I could
creep over to a stop Knight f4 King e2
who give a check I don't have to worry
about their king let's give a check
first then we're gonna take here and
then there I get my king up take my
queen yes game over back to tournament
king of the hill strikes rook takes
Queen King takes Queen on d4 gg back to
tournament land we are d4 alright I
think a good strategy is to eliminate
pawns proponent has pawns in the center
get rid of those guys let's go here and
maybe not be so quick to castle might be
a reason to keep your king leg here so
I'm not going to be so quick oh I could
have taken the night well take now
definitely
hack Kings moving up I like that idea
okay let's take care first let's do that
let's do that and then this come over
here pawn push I have this square
covered okay
get out of there Knight got no business
being there I have a bishop check here
get out of the way there's a fork I have
to be careful though I can't let the
King get here I got to break stuff down
there King is too close cut the King off
put the knight in a pin and I break this
pawn down the Knights pinned
one two three got it King d4 game over
back to tournament whoo man okay
Kasparov no caps Aarav okay I like
having a space advantage in king of the
hill okay they're not they're not gonna
weasel up their King anytime soon okay
my idea is going to be to the plant my
knight on c4 and play f4 and break down
that that structure to play here first
reinforce e4 whew okay let's do this
here still gonna do a little dance
it's my night getting to see for this is
a welcome sight having LightSquared
bishop exchange i don't think this one's
going to end any time soon like those
first two games it's just so closed king
doesn't even neither King has a great
chance of getting towards the center I'd
have to remove these two I'm getting a
brook okay they messed up there let's
break this pawn down okay
I still take Oh
it's open stuff up my King's ready to be
a fighter he's ready to run fast pawn
takes Queen takes King etude e3 e4 I
want to get my king right here and I'm
anytime 15 seconds what are they doing
let's go take my queen
let's go here don't move knight in big
trouble if you move know whatever real
care they don't have any ton anyhow take
my knight and I win
it's Forks let's take that take my rook
I win another down a time back two
tournaments ah okay eight eight six four
call five doctor chess all right any
players are in this one alright let's
start with the Sicilian I guess there's
always time that you could be falling
back on I build my Center okay
oh let's put it into that that's too
crazy you're not gonna have so easy a
chance get in towards the center with
the Queen's on board now you take me I
want to move forward
alright let's eliminate their pawn like
a whim aterial that is true huh but only
kind of blowing this um let's give a
check first no I shouldn't have done
that
oh I think King here and I would have
been dead I don't know how I would have
stopped that back here everything should
be fine now I should have done this how
about I start getting my king closer
good grief
on push would have been fine as well or
Queen takes pawn
I think I could have been in trouble
King f3 there let's push my queen will
stop the king from doing anything
exciting let's move forward here to here
is a threat how do you stop that let's
go here let's take with check here oh
just take this pawn
there's Bishop rook here but I get my
King to the center soon Oh actually
that's already me I was forgetting King
take King to e5 is made twelve nine
eight eight again capture of okay ah
let's try the four Knights I guess I'm
gonna take my night out
no ok let's pin your knight in a castle
that's a welcome sight let's get my
queen up clean side Castle pawn push
let's break it open I have this covered
my king can run by way of d2 real fast
okay mm let's just support that to keep
that night in a pin I guess here I kept
in the night not anymore
back up maybe they repair my structure
or not King up King c3 King c3 to d4 at
some stage how to remove that night I
think 25 seconds ok let's remove him
hit this pond I pressure here as well
okay this is this is this is good I
could have taken that pond let's check
be careful I was going to play King here
there's night-night trickery with taking
here let's do that stop King here my
King's ready to finally enter I win king
d4 back to turn with 21 minutes remain
sixteen thirteen twelve twelve twelve
eleven okay this is interesting I don't
know how big a fan I am of this variant
but we're going to give it a try c4
Queens gambit declined alright they're
not taking on c4 it's a pretty normal
ish stuff here I wish okay
okay I will take that guy no I'm not
going to I don't want to deal with
Bishop b4 mm let's go here okay now
let's get here hit that rook at the
night and you know what I'm gonna do
sack I want to clear this there Center
out so I could throw my king on e4 I
have a fast track to e4 keep going take
like this and you can't stop my king ooh
[Music]
let's go here
let's check and then King here you have
to stop these two how do you stop King
here here if to play your Queen here get
out of there Queen deflection one of
these to kill the Queen Queen here here
again mate next move King D for GG 19
minutes remain 20 18 16 14 12 12 again
it's like regular chess but you get the
King in one of the four center squares
and that's game over 50 players are now
in this woman less than 19 minutes
Dill's gambit live alright it's
developed normally it's too crazy to
come out too quick with the King this is
a repeat of the last game we're very
close to it
I keep pieces on board I have a space
advantage break down this pawn
I like Castle queenside with e4 very
weakening on the light squares okay I
already I'm already thinking about who
it's gonna be painful I might just I
could win by regular means checkmate 1 2
3 is a mate threat main 3G 6f8 queen h7
this is also matin 1/2 it's unavoidable
isn't it you're next no matter what and
that's game over I think so you can't
stop the bishop from controlling that
Square back to tournament 24:18 1614 h6
was too weak h6
the combination of age 6 and 6 was a bit
much light to New York and then all
right let's move forward grab some space
Nomad - with the king
Castle let's give a check here F for
king of two let's creep my king closer
not here I'm gonna take them let's do
this
what are you gonna do this I'm thinking
about doing this
wow what a plan you're ready to do this
are you oh that's a freebie that's a
free night let's just take care o is
that close to mate or what take the
Queen and then here I can't stop King
here and only a couple moves
no not even just one move back to
tournament king of the hill
28:22 eighteen sixteen sixteen drunken
master alright let's see what the
drunken master has up his sleeve in a
castle right away I love seeing that I
love seeing that okay I'm gonna have to
block here okay I'm fine with this let's
pin that night that's got to be a bit
uncomfortable no could've taken should
have taken should have taken G for maybe
I take rook on an open file line up um
let's be a pest it's also go here I'm
gonna drop c6 right here is gonna be a
painful move isn't it whoo okay let's
not do that
31 seconds this might just turn out to
be a rat race ouch
go here hit the Queen I want to play my
f-pawn up so my king has a fast track
towards one of these two let's take
there then here I don't have any time
forget about oh I didn't mean to do that
hmm oh it's a race okay I'm taking the
way from the centered king um oh how do
I stop there King from getting here not
good
oh no oh I can't yeah oh why didn't they
just move their king
they have me are they forgetting now
they're not forgetting GG king efore
Keeney for Best Buy test ah that end of
my streak to the drunken master got me
ah their night was so pesky let's go
night come on where do I stand twenty
eight twenty six twenty
regroup slow down there's plenty of time
regroup you're getting ridiculous
again there goes upon dr. Ches
um yeah I see it I see what you're up to
and I don't like it ah I'll do the same
oh my goodness was that terrible on my
part Keys have a Knight takes pawn with
check with authority their Kings gonna
play here oh man I don't like it
I gotta give it a check I think there
that's a claw
remove I think Bishop f5 very important
finesse go back
get out of there King get out of there
get rid of the knight take like this um
why am i grunting all of a sudden I want
to move my King towards the center
they're being pesky they're big pesky
aah
get out of there I need my Bishop to
control that square oh here
I don't worry about the dark squares
this light square what a bugger I could
cover this get out of there five seconds
I need a pond have that job five seconds
here no matter what here no matter what
they don't have any time check don't you
dare try to get this sir Wow was that a
dangerous King 34 30 24 22 uh-oh he's
got a lead I'm not adding he is he's on
a streak and he's got 34 ah less than 12
minutes remaining 34 30
the drunken master put a good dent he
couldn't he put a good dent right in the
streak it stopped me cold you've got as
far as you're gonna you're gonna go he
says all right I have a majority in the
center that I'm gonna hopefully put to
use sometime soon King f8 this is very
important King in the corner that can't
be right I went the Queen's off now oh
I'm on this file it's open it up even at
the cost of a pawn that's okay my king
is closed
let's weasel about Bishop c6 go ahead
take him we're gonna have a queen trade
if you do maybe
let's start out confident there he goes
okay this is this this must be a win the
king is a beast he's a beast in these
simplified endings give me that it's got
to be right or does it boom when you see
this move I think King d6 no that
doesn't work
hmm oh this works though King here how
do you stop that gotta go work here rook
here I think my king still would have
been faster can't be certain now to win
rook trade threaten here next with check
and then King here game over pact a
tournament oh ok 3432 I'm off I'm off by
two ten minutes remain twenty eight
thirty eight thirty two twenty eight
Kovach okay player who will always give
you trouble
oh I didn't mean to do that we're gonna
make it work though we're gonna make it
happen
let's go I like this idea of castling
and then getting the rook over and
playing King f1 just so he's a hair
closer towards the center no I will take
him the King's a fighter now he's a
fighter get ready what am i doing
let's take here maybe I'm gonna think
twice about yeah pull the plug on that
one
I'm gonna reconsider that I know there
goes our rook okay Bishop here let's
triple up Oh
tripled rooks pick trouble officer color
bishop bending my king is sneaky one two
three Queen trade opposite colored
bishops my King's faster towards the
center oh they're missing this this is
now win let's go here let's give a check
just to seal the King off don't allow
that pawn to move
now I have all day 1 2 3 they resigned
back to tournament 8 minutes remain 842
that we're both back on we're both in
streak here this guy is squeaky-clean
performance I might need to go in
berserk mode 38 36 I think we could
still just get paired up if we're paired
up that'll be a big one clearly what's
that move about hmm let's take that guy
on here are you gonna play Knight here
let's push let us push control you 5 now
how they finish their development oh
here I guess okay let's take oh this is
gonna be a win I feel like I could just
run up with my king now how do you stop
that
can't make next move Queen takes Knight
was needed but that's only delaying it
for a moment I have a lead now 40 38 oh
he had a slip-up here his streak
officially ended 40 38 28 now I don't
want to get paired up with them now I
don't want to get paired up I'm on a
streak I'm on a streak I don't want that
pairing let's see and they have space
leap in that night no we're not alright
they're gonna give me a center no ok
let's kick that guy out of there and not
sure what I want to do I'm so far off
with my king I don't know if I want a
castle just yet ok I have an idea I get
my Knight to f4 or even a bishop
exchange I could do this Queen h4 might
be an idea as well oh I like seeing that
I have a cover though get rid of their
night soon
let's open enough king f7 and I want a
castle and now you want to trade glue my
knight right in there he's an animal
he's beastly on d4 King f7 they're gonna
sack they can't deal with that night
they know it okay let's go opposite
their king make him feel uncomfortable
umm let's keep it close maybe 23 seconds
okay I want a clean trade Queen trade
and then get here huh not so fast
oh okay I could I have to take with the
pawn no I don't hang up
hang on check and then King here making
two threat in some cases of Queen takes
pawn take here now this and then mate
next not mate but King the hill mate
back to tournament five minutes
remaining forty-four forty thirty it's
not wise to go into berserk mode and
even if he wins he'd only get another
two before he's in streak mode okay five
minutes remaining forty four forty
thirty all right let's get two pawns in
the center how bad can that be soon at
least let's do that keep the pin Queen
d3 Bishop here I could have been a bit
uncomfortable let's get out of this pin
pressure here challenge the piece that's
in my position I wanna do f3 mmm they're
creeping closer I have c4 though really
I'll take them defend here in case uh I
don't know why Bishop here is going to
be tough to a deal with Oh
oh why was I not moving just then uh I'm
in trouble they're gonna take that pun
yeah oh no no their queen is too active
I gotta go Queen here just King f6 to
here was going to be threatened 30
seconds they have 24 they're thinking
it's a thinker King here to here oh that
works too that's even better I have to
give a check I think and then castle get
out of there King 16 seconds
um I guess take their I don't know what
to do I need to keep my Queen right
where she's at
um check for petrol oh what a move
that's a cool move I love that move it's
not a good sign for me I'm also down on
time Oh 44 40 oh okay he lost too
fortunately oh that was such a good
queen in the center I had such a
difficult time working around 44 43
we're not paired up um too late to try
and go on berserk mode okay it's gonna
come down to these last two games whoa
wow that King could get wild here I'm
gonna stick around towards the center
they could push me around okay take my
knight hmm I will take oh there's mating
ideas even do this there's mating ideas
with here Oh mate threats
maybe rook takes pawn that's me
this is mating forest Queen takes h3
next back tor backdoor stuff two minutes
remain 46 43 um I two minutes remain I
shouldn't go and preserve just play one
more game are we gonna get paired up no
if I win this I think it will be sealed
yeah it should be right go faster watch
out for the sneaky King undermined their
center get rid of these ponds get rid of
their pawns King f7 okay have a pond
towards the center here get some
development in he's ready to just
blunder like in a castle okay now they
can't castle this bishop is a beast a
beast on a six
he's trying though I'll chase him away
let's check huh oh I think they could
have taken and then played King here I
don't know how I would have stopped
stuff stop stuff it's very difficult to
stop stuff remember that okay
get my King on f7 get my King on f7
Queen trade gonna take my Queen there on
my bishop oh that's me wow that was a
sudden end to that game 4846 huh it's a
good thing I got that game in if he wins
one more that's gonna be it
oh I gotta watch out for him as well
he's only one point away I'm not gonna
get another game please just end hope
just okay who's on my heels chess leaf
um this is the only one that's playing
please don't win no that one's game that
one's over
get back here five four three two one
what's what's the count give me a little
trophy confetti trophy Oh
forty eight forty six forty five thirty
four thirty two hmm
it's the Marshall Arena I don't think
anybody went squeaky clean here I had
two speed bumps and I think a couple
other close what's that last one I think
if rook takes Knight in that last game
followed up with King III I don't know
how I would have stopped their King from
getting in the center
some goose eggs throughout yeah
tight pack up here 48 46 45 and a bit of
a drop off but could have been any one
of us through here all right
to those who played in that one the 56
of you good games all who else uh took
part in this just scrolling down all
right
there we go all right
games all
you
[Music]